passe les bras c'est son nom ça veut
dire balance en latin et c'est donc ce
projet assez peu mesuré de facebook le
genre américain lance sa monnaie
virtuelle
aujourd'hui pour un des bus
d'utilisation en 2020 c'est à dire
demain une monnaie qui pourrait être un
moyen de paiement en tout cas facebook
le souhaitent pour deux milliards sept
de ses abonnés mais aussi un formidable
nouvel aspirateur de données
personnelles en tout cas les nouveaux
projets de mark zuckerberg ne plaisent
pas du tout où ministre français de
l'économie à bruno le maire qu'on écoute
ça ne peut pas et ça ne doit pas devenir
une monnaie souveraine avec tous les
attributs de la monnaie c'est-à-dire la
capacité à émettre un titre souverain la
capacité à être une réserve comme eux le
sont les banques centrales
aujourd'hui prêteur en dernier ressort
tout ça n'est pas envisageable parce que
la tribu la souveraineté des états doit
rester aux mains des états et pas des
entreprises privées qui répondent à des
intérêts privés
mathias au caire tout sauf le libra ou
après tout il ya deux choses dans le
libre à 1 c'est une proposition de
monnaie mondiale mais privé donc une
monnaie mondiale
j'allais presque dire pardon c'est un
peu rigolo c'est en tout cas c'est
effectivement inédit dans l'histoire de
l'humanité et et et à l'heure de la
mondialisation d'une ouverture des
frontières et c'est l'idée même que
puisse émerger comme ça de façon un peu
spontané un projet de monnaies quasi
mondiale avec 2 milliards je suis
combien 500 millions de milliards c'est
ton ça fait réfléchir et qui plus est
une monnaie qui nous affranchit de tous
les processus d'intermédiation bancaire
etc
donc on a le sentiment en tout cas c'est
comme ça évidemment le facebook raconte
l'histoire ça va être
pardon que ça va être pour ça que ça va
être beaucoup plus rapide beaucoup plus
simple beaucoup moins coûteux pour nous
tous c'est que voilà ça va nous
simplifier la vie
donc la deuxième chose le deuxième
élément évidemment c'est le fait que
c'est une monnaie privée et cru dans
l'histoire tout de même battre monnaie
c'est a priori le monopole d'une
puissance publique
on a des entreprises aujourd'hui à
travers les gars femmes qui ont un
pouvoir une puissance alors pouvoir
puissances à discuter mais qui en tout
cas on détaille comparable à celle
d'état et est donc derrière un rôle
une responsabilité que j'oserais
qualifiés de politiques dont parfois
elles ne prennent pas bien la mesure
c'est ça qui doit poser question ça vous
ces peurs christophe de voogd ne fait
pas peur parce que parce que je joue
j'essaie d'analyser d'abord sur tout cas
c'est impressionnant des moyens qu'eux
mais que meyerbeer dans cette affaire
vous avez 20 27
associer une fondation indépendante
garanties mais face à levante arcus plus
grands spécialistes de ces questions qui
est ancien de fondateur de paypal
bayahi mais alors la question se trouve
c'est la science fiction qui nous arrive
là dessus la question de la réaction de
bruno le maire d'ailleurs est
intéressante de ce point de vue là
est-ce que c'est pas de step to match ce
qu'ils vont pas un peu loin et est ce
que dit risque pas d'y avoir celle
hesbaye compris l'état américain
vous savez qu'il ya on parle beaucoup de
plus en plus de légiférer sur les gaffes
à est-ce que ça en touchant un tabou est
en effet à une attributs de la
souveraineté est ce que là peut-être il
n'y a pas un peu du bri des mesures qui
pourrait leur poser quelques problèmes
escape a aussi olivier hamel on le
disait une volonté parce que sous des
dehors de de récupérer effectivement des
données d'avoir des choses très précises
sur les capacités financières des uns et
des autres oui à tout ça il ya la menace
que ça fait donc peser sur les
puissances publiques et à la démesure de
la puissance que pourrait avoir du coup
facebook puis enfin dernier élément qui
est une incitation probablement sourde
mais très efficace à la surconsommation
qui est pourtant un des maux de nos
sociétés puisqu'il suffira d'appuyer sur
un petit bouton pour payer en une
demi-seconde de n'importe quel achat
ce qui est pas tout à fait encore le cas
aujourd'hui donc il ya aussi ce danger
là c'est oui chat en chine qui marche
très bien sur le même modèle déjà ce
système là mais qui s'inscrit dans un
système totalitaire de contrôle total
des populations là qu'il faut comprendre
donc ça existe en chine
on est en retard sur les chinois oui
d'accord mais le monde tel qu'il se
dessine la chine est ce que c'est ça que
nous que nous voulons les gars sont des
quasi état ils éduquent il divertissent
il informe toutes les activités à peu
près humaine aujourd'hui se font en
ligne quelque chose qui n'avait passé la
possibilité effectivement de battre
monnaie ils continuent leur marche en
avant qui est de devenir des puissances
plus puissante que les états peut-être
que ce défi nouveau lancé aux états
suscitera la réaction qu'on peut espérer
notamment de l'antitrust américain parce
que ça viendra pas de l'europe ça
viendra de l'antitrust américain qui
fera comme ils font tous les cinquante
ans aux états unis rien bon il te casse
c'est de ça qu'on peut espérer les
zuckerberg n'est pas élu par ses 2 7
milliards de facebook qui les monarques
despote éclairé avis il ya un risque
le financier évidemment de ceux de
gestion de fait il ya un risque de
évidemment démocratique de ces on
s'effraie déjà juste titre quand et de
données qu'ils ont mais le jour où tous
nos mouvements monétaires on sait qu'on
s'inquiète aussi parfois de ce que nos
banques savent de nous mais le jour vous
vous joignez ce que savent nos banques à
ce que c'est facebook ou ce que c'est
google mais ça veut absolument tout dire
que ça sera des entités qui pour
accorder des crédits qui vont pousser à
la consommation pour le sata droit
d'acheter ça t'as pas le droit d'acheter
assuré fusée assuré regardez ce que dise
un truc
eric schmidt le patron de google quand
on s'inquiète quand on lui dit mais vous
allez tous à vrai dire si vous faites
quelque chose que vous ne voulez pas que
ça se sache
peut-être devrions-nous déjà commencé
par ne pas le faire avec ses salles
c'est une telle espèce de vote rallyes
terre au nom du bien à part au nom du
mal y pense pas du tout faire le malsain
blanc c'est une machine qui se déploie
d'elle-même tout seul et c'est
absolument proprement effrayant
magnifique réquisitoire nos internautes
sont alors on a la réponse on n'a pas la
réponse à la question du jour si la voix
6 86% d'entre vous ne souhaite pas
utiliser libre a en tout cas c'est pas
leurs intentions pour le moment et est
pour le moment où est le tout est dans
le pour le moment encore qu il faut il
comprendre où sera son intérêt parce que
c'est pas évident non plus pas dire on
paie pas d'impôts et une taxe est plus
de thé vert il ya plus tout ça puisque
quand on sait des monnaies qui échappe
aux états donc et plus tous les impôts
qui donc c'est aussi sans eau libre ce
que ces sociétés mettent en oeuvre ces
si vous passez par nous va vous gagnez
déjà tous les tous les impôts ce qui
pourrait donc faire le faire changer les
nuages l'an prochain on verra ça vous
reposera la question aux uns et aux
autres
en tout cas merci beaucoup à tous les
quatre merci à tous